well a good meal for a good cause is on
the menu for restaurant week which
officially kicks off today across las
vegas hector mejia live in the studio to
make us
all very very hungry a look at how you
can help this morning hector good
morning
where are we going to take part in this
today where we going good morning well
you know what we have more than 120
options to choose from and if you're not
hungry yet this will probably work up
your appetite
this is the 14th year for restaurant
week here in town and it has a bit more
meaning this time around
as the local culinary community tries to
recover from the pandemic and as we just
mentioned
more than 120 restaurants big and small
are offering deals all across the valley
really all around the valley and even on
the strip a three or in some cases a
four
course prefix menu they're giving a
portion of every sale to three square
foot bank to help those in our community
facing food insecurity
three square has been hosting restaurant
week for over 10 years now
so our restaurant partners have been so
generous giving back to us for all of
those years
over a half a million meals have been
provided to
people here in southern nevada that need
help you know a lot of us look forward
to this
all year long and it's a really a
win-win you get an amazing meal
help our local restaurants and give back
to those who need a helping hand around
the valley
and here's what you do uh this last 12
days so you have about two weeks and
here's what you do you go to the website
that website is restaurantweekly.org and
you uh
can already browse through the menu you
can choose a type of cuisine
you can also select the location
henderson the strip anywhere and your
price point
and again you can also already look
through the menu and even make your
reservations now so alex and john
i mean if you're not hungry yet you can
work up your appetite and
you can think about start to uh start
making those reservations
we're always hungry hector we're gonna
need to plan out breakfast lunch and
dinner for the next and everything in
between yeah
it's like it's like netflix when you're
looking at all the different movies like
you don't end up picking nothing because
you're looking at all the menus the
whole time along then you finally choose
one good stuff